qué gusto estar en este lugar donde se
resguarda la serpiente jamás pensé que
va a poder llegar a platicar pero lo más
valioso de toda esta experiencia para mí
en lo particular es este grupo de
personas con las cuales hemos convivido
ya 24 horas juntos prácticamente de los
cuales he aprendido cosas enormes
mis queridos expositores y expositores
todo mi respeto reconocimiento y cariño
porque este ha sido un evento
extraordinario gracias a ustedes un
aplauso para ellos muy muy bien
y nosotros nos tomamos muy muy a pecho
este tema de cómo podemos aportar el
hecho para que cada cual que pueda
renacer nos dimos a la tarea de entender
que cuadra cuál cost tiene hoy la misma
problemática que puedan tener muchas
ciudades de la república mexicana y
también del mundo entero 4 cuales vive
un problema tremendo que es el desgarre
de su tejido social este tejido social
que siempre ha caracterizado los
veracruzanos como unidad como una
amalgama de unión a través de su música
de su cultura de toda la cuestión
culinaria tan importante que tienen
ustedes pero también de cosas que están
dentro de la cabeza que tienen que ver
con el lograr emprender si bien también
la
capacidad productiva de coatzacoalcos se
ha visto mermada a raíz de estos enormes
problemas este es el momento de renacer
porque lo han dicho mis compañeros y lo
han dicho de una manera muy atinada el
poder no está en las instituciones el
poder está en la gente y cuatro cuartos
es una ciudad poderosa y así nos lo ha
demostrado durante los últimos 80 o 90
años pero qué significa renacer hemos
hablado mucho de este tema renacer es un
estado mental nosotros tenemos en la
cabeza la posibilidad de renacer vamos a
hablar de un replanteamiento que es
fundamental el replanteamiento de cómo
nosotros reordenamos nuestras ideas y
cómo también logramos hacer el cambio
todo tiene que ver con la creatividad
tiene que ver con lo que nosotros le
imprimimos a la manera en la que
nosotros hacemos las cosas de manera
diaria como retomamos eso como
impactamos eso en nuestras propias
familias una persona creativa no
necesariamente es alguien que es un buen
fotógrafo o alguien que sabe hacer
televisión
o alguien que sabe tocar la guitarra o
hacer una canción la creatividad tiene
también que ver enormemente con la
construcción de un proyecto en común
lamentablemente muchas veces nosotros en
el propio país estamos lejanos de estar
unidos y esa fisura que ocurre a nivel
nacional es la razón principal por la
cual nosotros estamos viviendo este tipo
de problemática particularmente en
coatzacoalcos donde es fundamental
rescatar los valores estos valores
familiares
estos valores artísticos los valores
también que tiene que ver con como
nosotros hacia el núcleo familiar
estamos permeando lo que realmente nos
importa y nos interesa es el legado que
nosotros le queremos dejar a nuestros
hijos como muy bien lo dijo ya ir hace
unas horas el progreso de coatzacoalcos
está en sus manos no está en manos de
nadie más no está en manos de un
gobernador honesto o deshonesto está
solamente en las manos de las personas
que quieren crecer y evolucionar a
través de ese cambio que es tan
importante
el cual a cual cosas que todos ustedes
están buscando que se busca desde la
cabecera del estado y que estamos
buscando nosotros como portadores de
ideas para contribuir a una sociedad
mejor está vinculado directamente a la
transformación paulatina y medibles del
puerto en muchas de las lecturas que
estuvimos nosotros realizando logramos
entender que cuanta cual contiene un
plan trazado a 20 años un plan de cambio
que hizo justamente el ayuntamiento hace
dos o tres años más o menos esta
transformación tiene que ser medibles y
tiene que ser paulatina y los ciudadanos
tienen que ver con que esto se lleve
perfectamente a cabo esta transformación
dará lugar entonces al bien común de la
sociedad
walsh a cualquier y también va a ayudar
enormemente a erradicar este instrumento
de control tan espantoso que ocurre aquí
y que ocurre en muchas otras grandes
ciudades del mundo en países altamente
industrializados y en sociedades que
parecen ser sofisticadas que estamos
hablando justamente del temor y de la
amenaza
cuanta cual cosa es hoy una ciudad que
sigue viviendo amenazada y lo peor que
le puede pasar a un grupo de personas
que son productivas trabajadoras alegres
y emprendedoras es estar bajo ese yugo
tremendo del dolor de la inseguridad y
de lo que es honesto en nuestro país que
está ocurriendo que es el terrorismo
méxico vive dentro del ámbito del terror
y esto es una cosa espantosa jamás
nosotros como mexicanos lo pensamos pero
hoy es una realidad de manera que la
estabilidad social es algo que es
importantísimo para poder lograr atraer
a esos capitales que se han ido poco a
poco del puerto nadie va a venir
invertir en 4 cuál cause si no hay una
garantía de estabilidad social la
economía viene directamente del bolsillo
de personas visionarias que están
decidiendo venir a invertir en
coatzacoalcos y están buscando una
estrategia clara por parte de las
instituciones trabajando de la mano
también con los ciudadanos para que esto
logre ocurrir y estamos hablando
fundamentalmente de las
si no hay seguridad por lo tanto no
habrá inversión jamás
esto se logra trabajando en equipo
nosotros muchas veces dentro de méxico
pensamos que el gobierno es que nos
tiene que proveer todo a nosotros que
ellos son los responsables de nuestras
desgracias y que nosotros como
ciudadanos simplemente somos explotados
pues no es así es el momento de entender
que cuál sea cuál pues tiene que tener
por sus pobladores y sus ciudadanos un
sentido de pertenencia si en ustedes no
existe de manera inmediata el sentido de
pertenencia y de decir yo soy de
coatzacoalcos yo puedo yo quiero un
mejor futuro para mi familia entonces va
a ser muy complicado poder presionar a
cualquier tipo de autoridad hoy en este
escenario hemos visto a hermosas e
inteligentes mujeres empoderadas
hablándonos sobre sus valores
hablándonos sobre estos puestos
importantes que tienen hemos visto
mujeres en pantalla también y el poder
de la mujer veracruzana y el poder de la
mujer de 44 es enorme esta mujer por
ello tiene un papel fundamental en el
desarrollo de lo que tiene que ver con
un plan y una construcción de ideas
imagen de coatzacoalcos está en sus
manos está solamente en las manos de las
personas que trabajan todos los días y
que se soban ese lomo para demostrar que
pueden hacer las cosas esa imagen se
tiene que trabajar a través de un plan
muy importante que por lo tanto genere
un imán de inversión y esta inversión
cuando llegue al puerto será producto
también de la credibilidad esa
credibilidad que tiene que venir de la
mano con un plan de objetivos muy claros
de cómo ustedes mismos y ustedes mismas
hagan las cosas la estabilidad la
continuidad económica también tiene que
ver con esa proyección que las empresas
a nivel mundial están buscando porque no
pensar en grande y por qué no pensar
finalmente que cuál sea cuál puede
brillar y puede ser una ciudad enorme
del futuro que atraiga la inversión y
que tenga la confianza de muchas otras
personas
por lo tanto pensemos en cómo queremos
ver a coatzacoalcos en el año 2040 a 20
años de distancia solamente son dos
décadas pero veinte años
son prácticamente una generación y
ustedes lo pueden lograr y también lo
pueden transformar
la mentalidad constructiva es algo que
todos necesitamos tener quien construya
es quien desarrolla aquella persona que
logra tener ideas y las logra poner en
la mesa de un plan de una manera
constructiva logra erradicar enormemente
el fatalismo es lo mismo lo que nos
hablaban también es un momento cuando se
suben ustedes a un automóvil y el chofer
les va platicando de lo desgraciada que
es la vida para mí la vida no es
desgraciado he aprendido a través de mis
compañeros y de mis compañeras que el
poder de la resiliencia si alguien puede
perder a un hijo y se puede levantar y
puede hablar de la manera en la que hoy
nos hablaron puede hacer cualquier otra
cosa seguramente ustedes han sido
vulnerados por el problema de la
inseguridad pero eso saben que está en
el pasado y no se pueden quedar con eso
porque si ustedes se quedan con eso
entonces va a ser muy difícil que sus
propias familias o sus hijos también
salgan adelante la participación popular
por lo tanto es sumamente importante
pero trabajando de la mano del gobierno
hoy también a través de
anna pudimos entender el valor de la
plástica pudimos hablar del valor del
arte
coatzacoalcos es una ciudad con enorme
riqueza cultural hagan un evento que
suene y resuene por todos lados del
mundo
reúnase con ya ir por ejemplo que
también es otro extraordinario fotógrafo
es una persona que tiene conocimientos
de cine guasa cual cos tiene que ser
proyectado a través de las artes para
lograr tener otra visión diferente para
poder hacer las cosas
mabel que es veracruzana puede venir a
apoyar esto también diferentes aliados
que se logren tener son fundamentales
para cambiar la imagen de puerto a nivel
mundial pero esto tiene que ver también
con la creatividad es por ello que
proponemos un festival que se llama viva
whatsapp que se empieza a trabajar desde
el día de hoy para que las artes la
cultura de kwanza cual ccoo y también
las actividades deportivas puedan
florecer y se consolide en los próximos
cinco o seis años
cuando hablamos de la reactivación de la
economía estamos hablando forzosamente
de la diversificación de los capitales y
la diversificación en la que la gente
está haciendo las cosas el capital
humano siempre va a ser y lo escuchamos
también de parte de sergio que fuerte es
la gente que trabaja dentro de una
empresa pero es mucho más fuerte la
gente que logra tener valores para
poderlos plasmar el reconocimiento y el
empoderamiento de la sociedad son
fundamentales para que el quad sea cual
cause logre también renacer y esas
nuevas inversiones van a venir en el
momento en el que nos convirtamos o 44
se convierta en una economía 70 80 por
ciento petrolera a una economía también
que si diversifique a través del apoyo
institucional de la educación por parte
de ustedes y la diversificación también
de las tecnologías los incentivos
fiscales son fundamentales eso es algo
que se toca ver a nivel gubernamental
para que las empresas que vengan aquí
puedan pagar eventualmente una menor
cantidad de impuestos para poder
invertir y lo más importante es un plan
de comunicación eficaz como ustedes
personas del puerto y también de la
localidad logren comunicarle al mundo
entero que cuanta cual cosa está
cambiando que están evolucionando y esto
tiene que ver con la manera en la que
ustedes utilizan la comunicación digital
para poder revertir también esa imagen
fuerte estamos pensando en coatzacoalcos
como una ciudad modelo como una ciudad
directamente del futuro una ciudad que
sea emergente que tenga por lo menos
cinco años de paz cinco años de
estabilidad económica y que salga de
este atolladero lo logro tijuana lo
logró puebla también y querétaro son
ciudades prósperas que son imanes de
inversión a nivel internacional porque
ustedes no lo van a poder lograr
ustedes son la gente ustedes están
empoderados y ustedes también tienen
toda esa necesidad y esa capacidad para
poderlo plasmar en el momento en el que
se logren unir los empleos la
estabilidad y son inmediatamente focos
de atracción que están cercanos a lo que
tiene que ver con la política
de inversión la infraestructura hoy es
petrolera puede crecer y se debe
diversificar también y debe haber
incentivos puros para el consumo para
que ustedes empiecen a tener ese
circulante y empieza a haber dinero en
la ciudad pero lo más importante es el
fortalecimiento de la educación a través
de las instituciones
es por ello que con base a este plan
actual que estuvimos nosotros estudiando
estamos proponiendo una estrategia de
cinco puntos que es lo que les quiero
dejar el día de hoy sobre la mesa
primeramente una colaboración activa
para de estar para restablecer el orden
social y el estado de derecho que es
algo fundamental número 2
diversificar también esta actividad
económica de la cual hemos hablado para
incrementar el producto interno bruto en
el tercer lugar tenemos el desarrollo en
el desarrollo y la capacitación
intelectual que es algo absolutamente
fundamental y la transición de los
servicios al cliente de lo cual ustedes
son también un modelo a seguir a poderse
enfocar en como digitalmente la ciudad
también se puede transformar y ustedes
pueden perfeccionar este tipo de
servicios el quinto punto de este plan
que es fundamental es el impulso y el
desarrollo de la cultura y también del
entretenimiento
coatzacoalcos y su espíritu son enormes
son ciudades guasa cual es como una
ciudad como lo hablamos y este espíritu
de la gente son fundamentales para poder
crecer el futuro es hoy como lo dijeron
mis compañeros y también mis compañeras
no podemos perder de vista que de los
más grandes artistas que hemos tenido a
nivel nacional y a nivel latinoamericano
han venido siempre del estado de
veracruz grandes deportistas grandes
músicos poetas gente que ha dejado una
huella enorme en lo que méxico está
proyectando a nivel internacional el
espíritu de ustedes su tenacidad y
también el incansable trabajo que están
haciendo es importante para volver le
inyectara cuasa cual con esa imagen tan
importante de la cual ustedes tienen que
empezarse a proyectar para generar un
interés diferente y generar entonces la
tan necesaria inversión cual sea cual se
tiene que convertir en un modelo
internacional de transformación
no permitan que el terror y no permitan
tampoco que la inseguridad los bajones y
les dé hacia abajo
ustedes valen muchísimo son una sociedad
creciente y una sociedad muy importante
la creatividad el trabajo en equipo y la
unión sin duda alguna es lo que los va a
lograr transformar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]